[Music]
thank you all for
taking some time out of your day to be
with us really looking forward to
talking about dashboard fatigue and how
to avoid it
and then just to reiterate what rob said
because it's always our perennial
question the recording will be available
uh and then we're gonna be going through
some slides as well as some code today
um that's available already if you want
to go to this link to follow along
it's a github repository that has the
slides as well as the code
so dashboard fatigue what are we talking
about before we can
address kind of that question we
actually need to take a step back and
think for just a second about
what the goals of a data science team
really are
and at the end of the day at our studio
we believe that the main
objective of a data science team is to
help
organizations and individuals make
better decisions that are informed by
data
and so that's you know a really
admirable goal
but it comes with its set of challenges
and one of the challenges that we've
seen
time and time again is that there's
often a gap
between data scientists and those
stakeholders they're hoping to inform
and that gap a lot of times is the
result of different mediums
so data scientists can be discovering
insight
you're writing code in our python
whereas decision makers often are
spending their time
either in meetings or in their inbox
or perhaps within spreadsheets
and more and more so uh they're doing
all of that kind of on the go
as they take care of a thousand
different things at once
often on their phone and so for data
scientists and data science teams we
have to find
a way to bridge that gap so that
our analysis can still be engaging and
inform and ultimately drive those
decisions
and there's a few different ways uh that
we've seen teams kind of close this gap
in practice
you know so one way that at our studio
we're big fans of
is building dashboards and so with
packages
like shiny on in the r ecosystem
or dash for example on the python
ecosystem
you can create these interactive
dashboards that are more engaging
for those stakeholders so they can
explore their
your analysis they can ask questions and
they can kind of
have an understanding that then allows
them to make better decisions
so that's one kind of practical and very
popular way to
close that gap of course there's other
ways as well
a lot of time and energy has been spent
explaining how data scientists can put
their models into production that often
is in the form of an api so that other
systems and services
can you know help take advantage of
those insights
and then sometimes here we might resort
to doing things like
modifying powerpoint presentations or
you're copying and pasting results
in kind of more more manual ways
so these are all different ways that
data science teams can bridge
that gap between mediums to make their
their work
more accessible to decision makers
but what we've seen is that sometimes
especially for
those really awesome interesting
exciting dashboards
data science teams can fall victims to
their own success
and so what do i mean by that well a few
weeks ago on
twitter angela bassa who leads the data
science team at irobot they make those
robotic vacuum cleaners she asked this
question on twitter
which basically said how do you keep
track of all of your dashboards
and this led to a really interesting
kind of exchange that
i want to show just a few of the
responses that she got
so it's one response it's that you could
go about making
a dashboard of all the dashboards so
kind of a meta dashboard
and this was actually the most popular
response to the thread
a very kind of data science way of
thinking about solving this problem
you know maybe i can use this the same
you know hammer that i
use to solve the original problem and
just make more dashboards
another answer uh what was this one i
found pretty interesting
a lot of teams will create kind of an
index of
the work maybe that is a
spreadsheet with links to dashboards
maybe it's a page on like confluence or
sharepoint
and of course the challenge there is
that you have to hope that you keep if
you remember to keep it updated
and then i think this answer was
probably the most honest which is that
a lot of times there's not a great
response you know data science teams can
produce
all these interesting dashboards but
there's no great way for
for others to to and keep track of them
and ultimately this is a problem because
it kind of impairs our ability as data
scientists to close that gap and inform
those decisions
often what we'll see is a really great
dashboard will
be created and users will engage with it
once
but over time in the coming days weeks
and months
the dashboard falls by the wayside
especially if there's
many of these dashboards it's just a
pretty
big burden to ask for your decision
makers your everyday
to go play around with the dashboard to
keep track of what's going on
and so that creates a problem for us is
that if we just wait for decision makers
to
proactively go visit our work we're not
actually closing that gap
but that's one problem we also see
something else kind of interesting
happen
as data science teams try to close this
gap
and so one one thing as we said is that
maybe the dashboards fall by the wayside
another thing that can often happen is
that stakeholders
will get excited they'll say great this
your insight makes sense
can you bring it to my medium can you
copy and paste those predictions into my
spreadsheet
or can you send me a screenshot of that
plot so i can put it in my presentation
and that leads to a lot of painful
labor-intensive work
uh you know one of the interesting
things over the last couple months that
i got to
work at home with my wife who is also an
r user
and one day looking over her shoulder we
kind of had this exchange
where she was doing exactly what i just
described she was taking the results of
some r code and plugging them into a
spreadsheet for a boss
and yet me being the our studio fanboy
kind of said why don't you create a
shiny app you know that'd be really
awesome it'd save you all this time
and you know it could be a big win for
your organization
and i wish i could have captured the
look on my wife's face
in her response here which is what she
basically said was like but my boss dave
has been looking at the same spreadsheet
every week for years
you know anyone who tries to make
changes gets
you know decimated basically uh and so
she was kind of stuck in this equally
problematic scenario i mean at least
her boss was engaging with her work but
it was in a way that
was really killing her productivity you
know we often refer to these as
fire drills where you have to answer ad
hoc questions that require a lot of
manual
labor intensive work especially on the
formatting
side if you're copying and pasting
results into different mediums
and so to summarize kind of the intro
here briefly
data science teams often can find
themselves trying to thread
this challenging needle uh where on the
one hand
you might put a lot of effort into
something really awesome like a
dashboard
only to see that it kind of falls by the
wayside on the other hand you spend all
of your time
kind of in these manual ad hoc fire
drills
neither of those are great ways to in
the long run close that gap
between data scientists and decision
makers but
i'd like to propose for you today an
alternative
a solution that we've found a lot of
success using ourselves here at rstudio
and so what does this solution entail
instead of creating a dashboard
what we like to do is create a proactive
notifier or something that is going to
alert me to the information that i need
to know
and in our case we spend most of our
time inside of our inboxes so that's
where our alerts goes is through email
but we still want to be able to do that
you know as data scientists
writing code and so so that's what we're
going to talk about today is how you can
use a rich set
of r packages to allow you
to create these proactive notifications
and as i mentioned kind of with my
wife's dilemma oftentimes these
notifications
need to meet the expectations of our
stakeholders for how they're formatted
so we'll look at some new packages that
are available
to help you precisely format these
results
and then finally we don't want to solve
this dashboard fatigue problem by
introducing another type of fatigue
which would be
email in fatigue and so we're going to
talk about how
you can only send these alerts on
conditions
so that instead of sending emails every
day
you can send emails more specifically
when there's a problem at hand and then
finally
we've been talking a lot about fatigue
we don't want to introduce email fatigue
dashboard fatigue we also don't want to
introduce data science fatigue
so we're going to talk about how we can
achieve these proactive notifications
in an automated way so that someone
doesn't have to click play every morning
the picture that you're seeing here is
one of my favorite examples of this
workflow
one of my roles at our studio is to keep
track of all the different r packages
that we
build and maintain for some of you on
the line our packages might be
a newer thing so briefly uh they're
just basically extensions of the r
ecosystem
they're sort of the bread and butter of
how data science gets done in r
they're also one of the main things that
we're responsible for at our studio is
creating these different r packages
and so every day we go and we build all
of these packages
and we want to know if that any of those
builds fail
especially if it's a really popular
package we don't want
uh to get a whole bunch of emails from
users saying hey this package isn't
available or doesn't work
we kind of want to stay ahead of those
types of problems
and so what a data scientist named greg
and i came up with
is this workflow where every day we run
these builds
and then if there's a problem and
critically only if there's a problem
do we get these types of targeted emails
that tell me exactly what the problem
was
and allow me to then take further action
and an example of that email
from my inbox is what you're seeing on
the screen
we're not the only ones who are kind of
using this pattern
successfully so just want to tell you a
few quick stories before we get into the
weeds of writing the code
one of my favorite stories is from a
large infrastructure as a service
provider
so a company that maintains thousands if
not hundreds of thousands of servers
and what they use this workflow to do
was
track their hardware uptime and then if
they saw a problem arising
they could send a proactive alert out to
their vendors
in the context of their support level
agreement or sla
and what this team was really excited
about is before adopting this workflow
they had done this type of task in jira
and anytime they onboarded a new vendor
or they modified
their sla they had to manually click
through a whole bunch of steps in jira
to accomplish
the you know this task the great thing
about this workflow is that it's all
based on code
so it's really easy to reuse you know
these different rules and different
markdown documents that you're going to
write and so this allowed the team to
easily cut down their their onboarding
time
another uh really awesome story of this
type of technology applied
was in a high-tech manufacturer
people-ops department
so kind of an hr group and they had this
challenging task where they needed to
notify division managers
about employee overtime problems so
you know say an employee worked more
over time than they were allowed they
wanted to send out an alert
now before they had a dashboard and what
they found
was their 30 different division managers
were not reliably going to that
dashboard every day to
check if there was problems and so they
adopted this workflow to instead
send out an email to a manager only if
there was actually a problem with a
specific employee's overtime submission
and they actually won an award of
excellence for adopting this workflow
which i think is is really exciting
because it's ultimately a pretty simple
concept that we're talking about here
and so if they're able to win excellence
awards i think that's going to be
accessible to
a lot of teams as well so let's get into
the nuts and bolts a little bit
to set the stage for rich who's going to
walk you through the code here
i just want to talk about the different
tools in our tool belt that are going to
allow us to apply this workflow
and so the first thing that i mentioned
is that we're going to be crafting
emails and to do that we're going to use
two r packages
the first one is our markdown if you're
not familiar with our markdown
it's a package that allows you to
combine code and text
to create documents uh beautifully
kind of customizable documents and so
historically our markdown has been used
to create you know pdf files or html
files
but in our case what we want to use our
markdown for is creating the actual body
of an email
it turns out an email's body is kind of
unique and different from other types of
output formats and so to help kind of
adjust our markdown to create the body
of an email
we've introduced a new package called
blastula and so that's what blasto is
really good at
is helping you craft the body of your
email
we also mentioned that often when you
implement these types of workflows you
need to format results in a very
specific way
and because of kind of the legacy of
spreadsheets
that very specific format tends to be a
table
and so we're going to spend a little bit
of time walking you through gt
which is a package that allows you to
have a lot of
control over the types of tables that
you can produce
from r and is also compatible with
blast linear markdown so you can embed
those tables right into the email
like you saw in my example
so those are kind of the packages and
then we get to what i think is really
the heart of this whole solution
which is how we can send these types of
notifications
in a more dynamic way on a condition
and the amazing thing about writing code
is that our answer here for
what can our condition be is really
endless
with code the answer is always yes that
is really true here
you know your condition might be
something like anomaly detection
it might be a complex model that allows
you to determine kind of dynamic
thresholds with uncertainty levels in
our case it's going to be just a simple
set of rules
but no matter what it is the actual
implementation
of sending a notification on a condition
boils down to a really simple if
statement
that i i think is kind of at the heart
of how powerful this workflow can be
and then finally i mentioned you know we
don't want to introduce data science
fatigue
so we don't want to use these tools then
still end up in a world where every day
we have to press play
on rendering these reports and sending
out these alerts
and so we're going to talk a little bit
about how to automate this workflow
now there's a lot of open source ways
that you could go about
doing this you could use something as
simple as crontab
to manage the execution of these reports
or
perhaps you could use a more advanced
scheduler something like airflow
but in our case we're going to look at
rsdo connect which is a professional
product
that our studio kind of sells and
what rcu connect does really well is it
takes care of some of the intricacies
of putting r into production so you
don't have to worry about the different
packages
that your report might need you don't
have to worry about logging failures
about authenticating users about
securely sending email
or scaling out the system and so it's a
really powerful way to kind of adapt a
lot of these automation features
without having to reinvent them all
yourselves so that's what we're going to
show you today
but the key to all of this i think is
that the code that we're going to look
at is actually really fun
to write and that's important because
doing something that's fun
is obviously a good incentive to do it
in the first place but also makes it
easier to share these types of workflows
amongst your organization
and to have other people kind of adopt
them as well which is
critical if you want to have you know a
critical mass
around this new type of workflow
so set the stage here for rich this is
what we're going to walk through in our
demo
we're going to start with some fake data
and then we're going to go from that
data
to a set of key performance indicators
or kpis that are going to serve as our
threshold for sending alert
notifications now in our case those are
going to be simple rules
in your case that's really where the
data science magic applies
and so you might apply some magic and
give us the benefit of the doubt here
and then what we're going to show you is
kind of a natural first step once we
have that data in those kpis
we're going to build a dashboard and
don't get me wrong
the point of today's webinar is not to
say that dashboard should go away
dashboards serve a really important
purpose in helping create mutual
understanding between
you and your stakeholders it's a great
way especially in like a meeting
to play around with the analysis and
allow stakeholders to bring
their domain expertise to the table and
maybe informing what thresholds or kpis
should be
based on their experience but it's not a
great place to stop
over time and so what we're going to do
once we have our dashboard
is show you how pretty much the same
code can be adapted
with the packages i mentioned blastula
our markdown and gt
to create these automated emails and
then we're going to put them into
production on our studio connect
and show you the output of what those
emails in an automated fashion
actually look like and so with that i'm
going to go ahead and stop sharing my
screen briefly
we're going to switch over to rich then
he's going to walk you through the code
all right here we are in my favorite ide
it's r studio desktop
i'm going to walk you through a few our
markdown files
and don't worry all the code is
available on this site
right here it's called beyond dashboard
fatigue
there should be a link available you
don't have to furiously screenshot this
code
it's all there the exact same files that
are here are in my id right now
so you can relax
so my goal here is to um to walk you
through
the different armored files which are
necessary for creating first a dashboard
and then creating the report and email
component
and not dwell too much on the actual
code except where it's important
but show you the structure and basically
the capabilities
of what could happen
so if you haven't used all markdown uh
the key is you have text
and you have some code it goes in these
chunks here uh you can render this by
hitting the knit button
so i'll do the right now to show us the
dashboard
okay so right now it's it's basically
working a way to create that dashboard
we get this preview window and here we
are with the dashboard
really easy we just use a little bit of
code here
to create these uh these panels right
here for all the different parts
so what i'm doing is i'm using ggplot to
create a uh
you know a daily user's chart
same revenue this is our business data
that's all available
inside the repo as well it's basically
fake data i made this
um but it's a great sort of like set of
examples to to show
us uh how we can use email functionality
to deliver
a report that's uh you know based on
business health
so that's what i call this uh so these
are different kpis
and i'll walk you through that in a
second but i just want to show you that
this is where we're starting from
uh we're starting from the dashboard
which in itself is great but
you have to actually look at this data
to know if anything is you know like
alarming with you know these kpis
so that's maybe not the best thing
unless you're extremely diligent
with looking at dashboards which may not
always be the case
so let's take that one step further
we'll go to a
arm markdown report so
without showing you the the actual code
inside chunks yet
i just want to say that the code is
essentially borrowed from the dashboard
but put into this main report document
and
same rule applies if you want to render
this you hit the net button
and you get a preview inside of our
studio
so i'm going to hit this and what we'll
see is actually two preview windows
because we actually have
a sub document here called business
health email
and that's the email version of this
report
okay so it'll make more sense when i
need it so i'll do just
that
okay so we get it rendering here
and we get two documents here so this is
the main report document
it is supposed to have lots of details
uh we have a gt table right here
front and foremost and we have the same
two ggplot
uh uh charts here and also some raw data
because it's a
sort of a full blown report here and
this is actually the email version so
it's a bit stripped down we don't have
like you know the final thing
like the final uh raw data we just say
the full report is available on connect
which it will be check the links below
uh because it generates those links for
you
and the raw data is attached to the csv
file which isn't here but
in the final version that we'll send out
it will be so essentially this is a
preview of the email
and it's quite a bit larger so we can
read it on phones
and you know smaller displays which is
great
but this is what we want to send out
only if there's a problem and we see
those problems here this cell's
highlighted in red
so let's have another look at the code
i'll walk you through that
and show you how we get to that point
okay well first of all let's introduce
the packages that we're using um
we're loading in tivers that gives us
things like deployer to
to bunge our data to to transform it get
in the right shape
uh lubricate for handling dates it's
very nice uh then we have gt
and blastula so this creates the table
that you saw there
blastula helps with emailing so we'll
use some blastula functions at the end
of this document
and glue is a really wonderful package
for um
it's like an alternative to paste so if
you want to make a string like say a
custom subject it's quite a bit easier
to use glue
and some variables that you've generated
in this document
so let me show you the first uh chunk
here i'll reveal this
the first part is essentially getting
your data in so get health kpis it's a
helper function
that's sourced in from these other r
script files
and uh this just gets us our data to
work with
uh uh you know in a different
circumstance this could be pulling in
database data it could be pulling in
data from an excel sheet
whatever the idea is just to get the
data into this report
and then we can apply other functions
what we're doing now is we're
transforming the data
and then we have a set of thresholds and
what we're doing with that is we're
saying that for each of these kpis
this one is daily active users daily
active customers
we have new users churned users and
daily revenue
and a ratio of data over dow and we're
saying that
if there's an exceedance um
this will be less than the threshold
that we set in a different file i'll
show you that really quickly right here
so this could be set uh by decision
maker uh this
will public meeting essentially this is
where the business health
is not so great if it passes these
values uh essentially we're saying that
all these ones
should be above these values and for
sure enough so you want that you know
the number to be lower is better so uh
this is our way of
saying oh yes okay we have a problem so
we're calculating those right there
uh and then what we're doing here is
we're getting some other variables and
we'll use these later on to
shape the um the subject line of our
email
to give us a little more information up
front so it's a bit nicer to sort of
digest immediately
okay so we've got some variables this is
not shown to the user in the report
we have a lot of include equals false
that means in the final report we don't
actually see this code
right you could reveal the code but most
of the time it's not very interesting
so we most of the time we just hide it
with equity equals false
so i'll show you this chunk here this is
where we make the gt table
again we're not showing the code we're
just showing the output of this which is
the table
and um it's pretty big here
essentially we start with the kpis and
then we're doing a few things to the
data and then we pass it into gt
and then we're doing things inside the
gt api we're adding up like a heading
or changing the column labels uh we're
using some helper functions that we've
created in a different file
to do some gt related things and we're
doing
some formatting of numbers and
currencies
and um this is quite a bit i mean we can
stop right here at just gt
and then you know we have a pretty good
table but this essentially adds more
formatting and makes the table
really shine they get more information
on this is available in the gt uh
repository
i will show that to you it's actually
just right here
it's gt.rgo.com you can learn lots of
stuff about gt
through that website okay so that's a gt
table uh ggplot poppy needs no
introduction that's
been around for a very long time tons of
examples
we're essentially reusing the plots that
we had in the health dashboard
and just putting them here uh we're not
showing the code we're just going to
figure and we're aligning it center with
this option
and this is the same thing with the
revenue chart it's just another gdp plot
right there
okay uh so another key thing here is
the email part so if there's a problem
uh on the last day should we send the
email or not
okay so here's the condition right here
if the total number of
is which is to say the total number of
problems saw in the most recent day
is greater than zero so if there are any
problems in other words
then we'll prepare this email we're
going to take this sub document
which i'll show you in a second which is
businesshealthemail.rmd
we're going to take that as the body of
the email
and then we're going to attach it to a
connect email
and we're going to create subject line
with glue
so the subject here is one or more kpis
total exceed
block thresholds and then we're having
some more glue code here
these color bases are essentially where
the variable total exceed which was
defined up here
is being sort of put into the string so
it's being interpolated into the string
it looked here there
and then uh here we're just continuing
the line and we're saying these are the
names
of the kpis that have problems
and you know collapse them as a list
with separated by commas
another cool thing is um we're actually
generating a csv file
right here just some data and we're
attaching it to the email
through this attachments argument this
is really cool because um
we can create any files here they won't
be seen by the user
uh in the main armored document but they
can be attached to email which is
fantastic
so this is the product so this is uh
what will happen this email will
be sent if we have any exceedances or
problems
uh if we don't then we suppress
the scheduled email okay this is a bit
confusing
um what does this actually mean so
in connect you deploy it through this
just publish the connect and i'll take
you to connect and i'll show you what
this actually means in context
which is right here okay so this is our
main document
our main report in connect so it looks
great
we actually have a history of these
documents they'll be published every day
but to do that you have to set up
you actually have to go to schedule
and then schedule this output to be run
every day
so it'll take all your code it'll run it
every day maybe on different data that's
kind of the hope because what happens is
you'll be kind to judgement
different data source well the same data
source will be updated every single day
so we'll get different data and possibly
different alerts so in this day we did
have
a few problems that are aligned here in
red
so that's great but we have to check
this every day
to see that there's a problem right when
we send email
we can send it when there's a problem
and we don't have to be checking this is
almost the same problem as the dashboard
having a report here
but the email sort of like solves that
problem so to schedule that
we sales really every day and the key
thing is to send an email after update
and then we set some recipients
it could be sean for instance here
oh sorry we have to go here first
and have him be as part of the
yeah on the list sean
great now we can save that and now we
have a master list of people that can
view our changes document and we can
schedule
uh connect to send emails to those
recipients through here
so i'll just do this one more time this
is kind of cool
great and we'll see this brilliant so
every day
it's going to be run and we can change
this of course but this is the daily
data so it makes sense to send it every
day
and it will send an email only if the
the thresholds were exceeded
and we can actually preview the email
send one to us yourself
just to you know sort of like um debug
the email and make sure it looks good
before it actually goes out
for legos production so i can send this
and i actually happen to have one open
so it shows it to me
right here this is my email client
so we can see that the subject here is
one of our kpis
and parentheses three that's the glue
work that we did here total exceed
uh broke thresholds and we have the list
of things here which is great because
if you look at this in your list of
messages you see this right away before
even opening up the email
and the body looks really good this
actually looks really wonderful on a
small device because the text is quite
large
uh we have just the important things
which are the table a little bit of text
just to sort of show what's being shown
and importantly here's the attachment
so here's the csv data in case it's
important wherever's looking at the data
it's right there uh so i want to show
you like how you craft this message body
in this business health email sub
document so a little bit strange
when i saw this previously i was
you know a little bit weirded out
because essentially these chunks have
nothing inside them
what's actually happening is we're using
the chunks in this main document here
we have anything as long as the names
match across documents
all the content will be transmitted to
the sub document and then the email
which is really very cool it reduces
typing reduces code duplication we can
have one
source of truth which is fantastic so
yeah we're essentially adding a section
here some text
the output stating that the full report
is available on connect check the links
below because the links
are given here at the bottom and these
are real live links that send us to the
main report
if you want more details and i say that
the data
is attached to the cs file which is the
truth it's right here
so this is really great uh and we're
using some of the code
that's you know in the email as well
this paste
and this is our markdown so we can use
markdown with uh
the asterisks to make things bold
so yeah um let me go back to this
business health
our market document and i'll show you
this one more time
in case you missed the person around if
you knit this you do get a preview
locally
so you can sort of debug it before it
even gets to connect
there we go yeah and again the strange
thing is we get two previews
one is the email which appears in your
browser
and one is the main report which will
appear in connect
yeah and that's really about it
um i just want to impress upon you that
the main thing is this
very important bottom chunk it relies on
having blastula available
which is uh the clerk right here in the
sub chunk library blastula
because these two functions are from
blastula render connect email
and attach connect email
and as long as you have the condition
set properly we should expect that
email will be suppressed because it'll
be by default
sent out every day unless you know this
condition
is you know unless we're going to the
false condition here
that's about it uh went through it
pretty quickly
but that's okay because i want to leave
lots of time open for questions
and uh yeah and
what i'll do now is actually go to the
slides
right here to let shawn finish
yeah thanks so much rich um
that was awesome i hopefully everyone
saw kind of
got a sense for her for the code and how
easy it is to
to write to implement these types of
workflows uh
lots of questions that we'll go to in
just a moment that they were coming in
that which
are all excellent just to quickly kind
of
recap in case maybe you were late and
just a bit of the introduction
you know the goal here is to help data
science teams empower
really good decisions uh and what we've
kind of seen in our experience and what
rich just showed you is that it can
help data science teams do that if
they're able to more proactively
distribute their work
instead of relying on decision makers to
kind of diligently
visit a dashboard on a regular basis
as rich also kind of showed this
workflow of proactive distribution is
pretty easy to do
because there's a rich toolkit of code
so you
can write the code that you you love to
use even if your decision makers are
receiving results
in the media that they like and then
just as a kind of general rule the more
tools that we as data scientists have in
our tool belt
the more likely we are to kind of more
likely we'll be able to impact decisions
in an effective way
so that's kind of the take home message
uh to reiterate
uh the recording will be available but
the slides and code already are
so if you want to dive deeper into what
rich
covered and kind of re-run those
examples
you can certainly do that by going to
the short link there that'll bring you
to a github repository
with all the code and examples
so at this point we have a pretty fair
amount of time
to walk through some of the questions
that have come in
rich i can go ahead and answer
uh and we can kind of tag team this so
one of the
first questions that that i saw that i
thought was really interesting
was a question uh that asked what types
of things can you
embed in the emails so we demonstrated
uh embedding
ggplots and tables uh this particular
participant asked about
interactive html widgets i'm sorry so
rich maybe if you can
give a shot at answering that yeah well
not
it's a little bit of a letdown but not
really uh because email clients do not
like any javascript in their email they
tend to strip those away
um so that is kind of out
um the most interactive you can probably
get is
simple html elements and links to like
say a full featured app is what people
are doing in email
so interactive bits like html widgets
are kind of
not possible until like email
you know gets beyond where it is now
right now it's very it's very uh
it's very stripped down because of the
security model of email
so that's a bummer answer but it's uh
basically don't try yeah the the
kind of a follow-on question was
um we think he showed apple
mail which got some applause from the
audience rich
but but we'll throw out there that the
approach has you've been kind of
validated and tested on a whole bunch of
email
clients so for those formats that are
supported
um you'll be able to you kind of use
outlook gmail
kind of whatever on your phone or on a
laptop
i'll throw it in there that we made a
very large effort
in our qa process to test as many
email clients as possible with a range
of
you know sending types with blatula
through connect
just sending through your own smtp
server
like via gmail uh we're actually using a
service called bidmis
which will you send them the email
and they will test it on 50 plus you
know email clients
and we can see the results and if things
break so we were able to fix a ton of
problems
and more importantly to ensure that you
know your email will
be delivered without being mangled which
is
always a good thing awesome
uh i'll take so another kind of group of
the questions here rich was um
you know what what if you don't want to
use rco connect
um and so i can take a stab at answering
that
um kind of the the key to all of this
that there's two parts that you would
need to implement
one is a way to kind of on a schedule
render in our markdown document
and there's lots of different ways to do
that you can use something like cron
you can use something more sophisticated
like airflow
or you can manually click render on a
report every day
so there's lots of options there the
second bit
is that you need to use a service that
will
send the rendered email
and so rich mentioned briefly and maybe
you can expand upon this rich
but blastula also has functions for
integrating
with non-rco connect email senders
like an smtp service yeah that's right
so you can
use gmail's smtp service you can use
microsoft's outlook one the online one
and you can also hook up any other ones
like smtp2go which is a really nice one
um but the problem is it's not really
reliable i found connect
is rock solid always sends your email
sometimes you get throttled with those
other services
um so that's a little bit of uncertainty
you know you may have to deal with but
uh
it's possible yeah the other thing i'll
add to that rich
that you will want to be a little bit
careful of
is that when you're sending these types
of notifications
you just need to watch out for kind of
impersonation
issues and so one of the things that
we've worked hard on
connect is to make sure that when you
send an email it's coming
even though it's an automated system
it's coming from a reputable
address and then going to the people
that are designated to see it
and so there are some security
ramifications when you get into the
realm of automating notifications
that you just want to be careful of if
you're integrating with one of those
other options yourself
let's see uh in terms of other
interesting questions uh swannett
asked a pretty interesting one which is
do you have to use r
or is there a way to incorporate other
languages like python
into these types of workflows
i'm sure there's a way but the the thing
you're missing is like
blastula for you know creating the email
message body
and python does have it might
you know i've looked around and i've
looked for other
um python libraries that do
this sort of thing like create email and
certainly you can send an email right
through python but the hard part is
creating the message body
and even harder part is creating an html
message body
which is what blastula does um so i
think it's possible
you just have to do a lot of upfront
work you basically have to reproduce the
lastula
in python um to get that going
i'd love to find out if there are any
other packages or sorry libraries in
python that actually do what
flashlight does but in my search i
couldn't find any
i'll add to that rich um you want one
kind of way that you could combine these
two together
is actually within our markdown and so
it's a bit of a misnomer but
our markdown allows you to combine a
whole bunch of different languages
so while it's in our markdown document
you can certainly have
python code chunks commingled with r
code chunks commingled with
bash code chunks if you wanted or sql
and so all those different languages can
live inside the our markdown document
and then our you know and that
type of workflow just becomes a
facilitator for
sending the email using rich's awesome
work on blastula
yeah i just brought that up because yeah
definitely all the other stuff you can
do in our markdown it has a lot of
engines
available and uh but the the last piece
is kind of critical
so so this is kind of an interesting
question uh rich on
a little bit more kind of philosophical
i guess uh
the person asks how is this approach
influencing
kind of your thinking around dashboards
uh you know
and kind of when you would use a
dashboard and when you wouldn't
ah yeah a dashboard it's still pretty
essential like um
but i wouldn't use it as a way to notify
people of anything important
right because it involves diligence in
you know
seeing the dashboards daily or you know
whichever you know whichever frequency
is
required to be ahead of like important
issues
so it dashboards is part of the the
whole thing like you can go to a
dashboard
once you get notified and then you know
get you know get the history of
what what led to certain problems up to
the present day or whatever
um it's not a replacement for a
dashboard it's basically this
basically adds to the whole stack of
analytics
and one thing i'll echo there that also
kind of addresses another question that
was asked we kind of touched on this
very briefly
but a common pattern in those emails
that you send
is to dynamically generate a link back
to a dashboard
and so something that we do a lot at our
studio in the example i mentioned at the
beginning
i'll get an email that says hey these
packages failed to build
and then it includes a link to a
dashboard where i can
explore like the error codes and the
duration of the job and all sorts of
more kind of interactive questions
and so dashboards aren't out of the
picture
they just as rich said aren't the
mechanism for
doing the notification yeah exactly
uh there was a question here uh instead
of hard-coding the thresholds
they can be dynamic right yes
of course this is basically your code i
just i just basically whip something up
together
very unsophisticated whether it's below
or above
you can definitely pull in data generate
the thresholds dynamically
compare there's lots of ways to do this
you can use
packages like anomaly detection or
you can use like the forecast package
to do certain things essentially what
you want to do is you want to get to
a place where you can make a final
decision on whether it's an email or not
and then what to put in that email and
and you may have different versions of
email um you may select between
you know different types or you may be
more sophisticated in the dynamic
content you include like a subject line
or even
content in email because the variables
are transmitted from the main document
to the sub document
which is kind of cool so yeah
basically because this is code you can
do whatever you want
you can you can go nuts essentially
yeah a uh a kind of follow-on question
uh it was you know maybe as
a data scientist um i don't know the
triggers or thresholds and so the
question was
does it always fall on the data science
team to set them or is there some way
for
decision makers to influence the
thresholds
yeah that sort of thing i think it's a
conversation between uh
the data team and the
decision makers in the organization for
sure
uh you may have a set of recommendations
you may change them
uh on a weekly basis or some other
frequency it may be dynamic it may just
be a system which creates thresholds if
values are changing fast right and
there's seasonality or things like that
so it really depends on organization but
essentially it should be transparent i
think
because decision makers are getting the
notification they probably should know
why
and uh yeah basically it's a
it's a conversation yep and you know
the nice thing about about code is that
you know it's
it's not a black box it's very
inspectable and it gives you the
your full flexibility there so you're
not locked in you know it's not like our
studio is deciding what the threshold
should be for you
um you get all the options there
uh yeah and it did that kind of leads to
another
question that came up that i thought was
really awesome that this
we talked a lot in this webinar about
creating notifications
to bridge the gap between data
scientists and decision makers
but this person asked could the same
workflow apply
uh to notify the data science team of
data quality
issues absolutely yeah
definitely yeah i mean it's totally up
to you
who the emails are directed to uh you
know i would set up diagnostic emails to
yourself
you know if important uh if certain data
um you know is dustbin based on
some you know some data validation rules
that you have
i would want to know about it and then
you know i would want to let data
engineering
know about it too to get at the root
cause of things so absolutely yeah
definitely send send yourself these
notifications
yeah that's my uh that's my pitch so so
those were some high-level questions
there's a few kind of more in the weeds
questions
that will address here kind of at the
end um
one of them is from someone who's
already playing around with the code
so yeah kudos to you and
they've hit a kind of a stumbling block
that
is uh maybe a little bit common as
you're kind of learning this workflow
um and rather than reading the question
verbatim rich i'll basically
diagnose it and maybe you could even
show kind of the workflow here
but um essentially what they did was
they rendered the child document
instead of the main document so can you
talk a little bit about kind of
which document to render and when yeah
so this is a trap i always fall into
because it doesn't stop you from
entering the trial document
so it's always the main document so if
you render the child document
nothing good comes from that yeah there
should probably be a warning somewhere
but there's nowhere to put it but
essentially it all comes from the main
document
and that gives you two previews so
basically the thing you want to ask
yourself is
am i saying too previous and if not i
probably did something wrong
so always hit knit on the main document
and then you'll be you'll be a-okay
otherwise it'll
it won't harm anything it just won't
give you anything useful it'll probably
just give you
something you know it's not great yeah
the error messages that you'll
tend to see if you accidentally knit the
child document are you that variables
are
undefined and that's because those
variables are defined in
in your main document now of course you
could
duplicate all the code into the child
document to have a child document
that's also standalone but then you sort
of needlessly
copied and pasted code which is
something that we're always trying to
avoid
yeah try to try to keep dry even your in
your email message bodies
or your arm are done documents so so
people that don't know what dry means
don't repeat yourself
try as much as possible to have one
place for code
and that's the great thing about these
sub documents taking results from the
main document
you don't have to rewrite code and worry
about you know
being in sync but between the documents
excellent um and then
just for the sake of your being in the
weeds
with our audience here uh maybe one
final
question for you rich this one was
related to gt
which we spoke on briefly and they said
uh
how to apply how would you apply the
same row rules
across multiple columns um
and maybe you can just use this as an
opportunity rich just speak a little bit
more towards like what
the kind of philosophy is behind writing
gt
code and doing the types of highlighting
that you demoed today
yeah basically we do with highlighting
is you're using uh tab style
and you're specifying the either the
whole row
the whole column or an individual cell
with the locations argument
so it's basically like you're on an
excel sheet and you're clicking
something
to highlight it and then you're doing
this you know bit of styling
which could be changing the text
changing the background the cell
whatever um how would apply the same
thing i would just use the columns
argument
and specify multiple columns with within
bars
that's how you normally do that i would
try that first if it doesn't work
um then it might be something a little
bit more
to it and if the question is
super important i would definitely ask
it in our studio community or
even inside the gt issues uh
sort of like page in the repository
excellent yeah so so i think that's kind
of a good
stopping point um it allows us a chance
to echo
a couple of things so one is thank you
you know for both for spending your time
listening to us but also for these
excellent and engaging questions uh if
we didn't get a chance to answer your
question the best place to go
is the rstudio community and there will
be a follow-up thread
that is available to you specifically to
ask questions on this webinar
so that's a good way to continue the
conversation there was some questions we
didn't get to address
specific to our studio connect if you're
an rco customer you can reach out to
your customer success team
if you're not you know we would love to
talk to you about kind of what
problems you're trying to solve and how
we can maybe facilitate those
uh the packages and code and recording
will be made available
and you know again we just really
appreciate your time and hope that this
type of
dynamic notification can help you as
data scientists
or decision makers ultimately at the end
of the day make more informed decisions
which is what we're all after
you